Kelly left the channel in January Marisa
Guthrie is media reporter at The
Hollywood Reporter Marisa good morning
morning Bill O'Reilly is leaving after
just signing a mega deal with Fox to
continue even though these charges have
dated back to 2004
what remaining questions are there at
Fox well I think that that the fact that
they signed him to a new contract
knowing that these allegations were
going to come out obviously there were
earlier allegations than everybody knew
about and know and that they were doing
this paint there were settlements being
paid after Roger Ailes is exit under the
same sexual harassment cloud produced a
lot of anger internally and made women
there question whether the Murdochs were
committed to a workplace based on
respect as they said do you believe they
will feel that now after this decision I
do I do and I think the women who were
afraid to come forward because they
never thought Roger Ailes would be
ousted had a new voice within the
company yeah what are you hearing about
the role that women at the company
played behind the scenes well they were
they were really disheartened there was
people described it to me as outrage
that these revelations came out post
sales that they had they had they had
obviously renewed his deal knowing that
this story was coming out so they made a
calculation then that they could weather
this and I think that is what produced a
lot of the anger internally and do you
think it was more than just the
advertisers dropping out because they
dropped out from Bill O'Reilly's show
but Fox was still getting money from
advertisers yeah they were not they were
not taking any real financial hit on
advertising because they were just
moving there their ads to different
shows on Fox but the stock price did
slip the stock price slipped on
perception perception that the the house
is not in order over there and when you
have internal unrest that's something
that executives worry about a lot so the
tipping point exactly was in your
judgment I think it was it was a
combination of the women inside the
network not just women but the people
inside the network
were concerned about this and outraged
about this and also the the perception
on Wall Street that produced a six
percent stock dip since these
revelations came and how about that New
York Times piece that revealed that they
were being that they had paid those
women yeah that that is what produced a
lot of the anger that this was still
going on after the Murdochs had put out
that statement when they made the
settlement with Gretchen so how do you
think Fox will do Maresa without Bill
O'Reilly well they're a very strong
brand they're also a brand that has a
monopoly on conservative opinion on
television on cable news and they also
have the wind at their back as does all
of cable news because the political
junkies are just glued to it right now
with the early tumultuous is anybody
know whether there was decision between
different between Rupert Murdoch and his
two sons in making the decision they
were all they all came to agreement I
was told on Tuesday about this but the
three of them but yes there was early
separation daylight between Rupert and
Lachlan and James and then James and
Lachlan were aligned and then the three
of them and then we heard James and
Laughlin's wives also weighed in right
exactly exactly Maresa that's right good
to see you thank you thank you thank you